if you find yourself becoming a holistic
arrogant conceited or puffed up think of
mortality or think of other arrogant and
conceited people and see how they look
do you want to look like that do you
want to take yourself that seriously to
be that on humorous
I really like that Scott welcome to the
show ha thanks Chris so great to chat
with you today really exciting to speak
to you today so we're talking about
transcend we're gonna be speaking about
self-actualization kind of at the moment
I suppose the way that people view their
own lives and what they can do with them
is probably a pretty timely topic at the
moment right I would say so I think
people are struggling in a lot of ways
that they are perhaps losing sight of
the self-actualization that that's
possible within them it can be very easy
to lose sight of the greater
possibilities for yourself and for your
fellow humans when you're pitched in the
state of insecurity mmm so I know that
you're a big fan of Maslow and you base
a lot of what you do on top of some of
his work I guess is okay these are
pretty cool um I'm gonna guess that at a
time like this where people are very
concerned about some real basics the
bottom of the pyramid were worried about
the health family's health
you know there's food and water
shortages you see these images of Costco
and everyone's ripping [ __ ] off the
shelves and stuff like that like does
that I know and toilet paper they're
ripping the toilet paper you know or the
toilet paper is the maddest thing
because it does it doesn't affect your
digestion but that's that we could go on
forever about that um how does that
relate do you think to the way that
people are seeing their lives at the
moment the fact that they're more
immediate primal needs are kind of
brought to the forefront so what is the
question exactly how do I like well how
do I perceive the situation so at the
moment what we're going to be talking
about self actualization and trance
after is there a
bound that's being placed on that by the
immediacy of people's arms at the moment
I see what you're saying well there
certainly is and and that's the the
great tragedy of falling prey to
insecurity and uncertainty what I mean
by fallen prey is there there's always
going to be uncertainty in our lives
we're in this it's funny people are just
are acting as though the situation is
like the first time in their life that
there's great uncertainty I mean there's
there's there's equally probabilities
actually greater probabilities of things
when you cross the street every day in
your life you know you don't think about
all these things you know but here there
there's there's a thing we could see on
the media there's a thing we can see on
TV where you know people are talking
about it every day is this is nothing
but it turns out and I hate to break it
break the news here breaking news Scott
Barry Kaufman breaking news you know
CNN's like brings my way so Scott yeah
breaking news you have lots and lots of
things [ __ ] that can go wrong in terms
of my priorities of things that go wrong
the co vid 19 is is is is pretty
prevalent but I wouldn't say that's my
number one thing I'm concerned about in
my day I'm just trying be mentally good
through the day so look there are lots
of things and I think the the managing
uncertainty is a lifelong skill and if
there's any silver lining to the moment
we're in right now is that maybe we can
maybe now is that now's the time to
practice you know hopefully our all the
listeners and and people around the
world will will make it through this
healthy and safe I certainly have that
wish for everyone but if there's any
silver lining once we all get through to
the other side it's that may be this is
a great opportunity to learn some of
those important uncertainty management
skills that we probably should have been
learning throughout the rest of our
lives not not just in this moment I
couldn't agree more there's this great
example about uncertain see the
Southerland my friend from Ogilvy
advertising told me he was talking about
London Heathrow and he was saying that
the wait times at London Heathrow to get
through the security scan section were
just causing abhorrent amounts of
complaints was taken too long people
getting excited so originally they went
to London Heathrow and they said what
have you tried what have you been
looking at doing and because of the sort
of people that run an airport logistics
operations optimization stuff so they'd
looked at can we rotate the staff in a
different way to make sure that they can
move quicker where can we can we
condense the lanes down so we can fit
more lanes of people in can we do they
looked at it as a logistical
optimization problem and they brought I
can't remember if it was Rory or one of
his friends in and they said right
before you do that before you spend
several million pounds on new staff and
new equipment let's just try one thing
and along the queue where you waited to
get into the security scanning area they
just placed little posters that said
45-minute wait from here 30-minute wait
from here 15-minute way from here well
Disneyland
yeah and the number of complaints
dropped by like a factor of ten they're
just completely annihilate it because
people don't mind waiting
they don't mind being in discomfort they
just want to know when it's going to end
and that is that's the uncertainty right
we don't know when this is going to end
that's exactly that's exactly and it's
particularly stressful for those who
score high on a personality trait called
neuroticism so people who score high in
neuroticism would prefer the devil they
know to the devil they don't know so I
imagine there are some that maybe they
wouldn't admit it in play company but
they're almost like gave me the [ __ ]
virus already you know like let me get
over with it over with it because it's
actually more painful to my mental
health
to not know when it's coming because
they say it's coming they say there's an
80% chance that you know that you're
gonna get it probably you know not that
you're gonna die from it may only be
clear but that you'll even you know
it'll you you might even be symptomatic
but you'll get it you know that some
we'll probably like secretly being like
just give it to me alright but we might
a lot of curse in your podcast I know I
just there's a way all you want Scott
thank you thank you so let's let's let's
get into it what is how do you define
self-actualization what is it I've heard
people speaking about you but don't know
what it is I'm say one more time what is
self-actualization how the question
that's the question
well people have to misrepresented
Maslow's ideas of self-actualization and
in for instance David Brooks Souza New
York Times columnist really was hating
on Maslow a couple years ago and wrote
something about how Maslow's ideas of
self-actualization or the cause of the
self-esteem movement we had in America
where people call it can be anything I
want cuz you know I'm good good enough
and doggone it people like me you know
that's the that was the skit from
Saturday Night Live if you're familiar
with that's good
but it turns out it's not true I mean
that's not fair and when I read that I
was like oh you know like and actually
got Brooks on my podcast and I said oh
hello whatever I still have great
respect for him but I was just being spk
being sbk but you know this is the thing
is like he the Naza really made it clear
that to fully self actualize we have to
eventually transcend ourselves that self
actualization is really only a bridge to
transcendence you can't reach your full
potential if you you're not helping to
reach the full potential of others like
yours you're not reaching your full
potential you know people talk about
reaching their full potential as though
like they develop that it stops when you
develop your talents to its full
capacity and there's a lot of people in
the self-help space people you know
you're probably very familiar with this
you know that have that
conceptualization like they're high
level highest level goal is like
greatness that's it and then you're done
as though greatness defined by them
might only mean out achieving everyone
but that's not full greatness you know
that's not the
fullest potential Maslow really tried to
show people a vision of what humans
really could be what our what our
highest ceilings of human nature really
could be kind of pulling the way forward
for that and that's what I tried to do
in this book as well in that same spirit
and show that full self-actualization is
not just an individualistic pursuit it's
becoming all you're capable of becoming
that is true we can define
self-actualization as quite simply as
becoming all that you're capable of
becoming but that all you're capable
becoming part actually requires
uplifting other people that make sense
so that's what's greater than greatness
greater than greatness is you making
other people great as well transcendence
greater than greatness is transcendence
yeah I like it so past modern wisdom
guests Aubry Marcus has this really
beautiful quote where he talks about how
in order to serve you have to be fit for
service he says you don't serve other
people from your cup you serve them from
the saucer that overflows around your
cup um what I'm wondering here is we've
talked about the peak of greatness the
transcendence above self-actualization
being raising others up as well can you
raise others before you've raised
yourself or do you have to conquer your
own Mountain before you move on to them
great question I think that you do have
to conquer your own mountain you really
have to do a lot of the inner work first
I what I try to do in this this book is
show that in order to transcend yourself
you need a self that's transcended you
don't need to sacrifice yourself there
are some people who are trying to
transcend and and have a sense of
self-sacrifice where they almost feel
guilty to first be great you know and I
don't I don't think that's that's that's
the best way to help the world is to is
to squander your own talents in any way
I don't I don't see these things as
mutually exclusive I think the best
thing is for a transcendence the best
thing for for
to be most effective is when there's a
seamlessness between yourself in the
world because yourself that you've
developed or your talents and capacities
and strengths have been developed to
such a degree that you're being just by
being in the world helps uplift others
so there's a seamlessness between soften
world that's the greatest thing is when
there's a harmonious integration between
self and world not when you've made a
self sacrifice to such a degree where
you're where you feel as though you you
don't matter and the only thing that
matters are other people that I don't
want say that's the healthiest thing I
think some people as well they fall prey
to being they sacrifice their own
progress or they perhaps recount trying
to have objective measures of success
and they do that in order to avoid
having to play the game of success and
prove themselves
I was wondering asked Aubrey this the
same question of how many people that
follow an ascetic tradition now you know
modern day I'm not bothered about money
man I'm not bothered about possessions
man do it simply because they don't want
to have to get down to brass tacks of
doing some hard work and it's very easy
to signal that you're being very
charitable and altruistic and helping
other people but all the while having
never conquered your own mountain you
know yeah it's it's true i phrase it as
pseudo transcendence or pseudo growth
there are a lot of people that are
trying to have you like that there are
lot of people that are trying to grow on
a faulty foundation and we all know what
happens when you try to build anything
on a faulty foundation you get the Trump
Tower now I'm joking I'm joking I'm
joking don't put no one cast no one
cares over here I mean 50% of the
audience is in America but no one cares
over here you got no enemies in the UK
okay I'll go see no but you know when
you when you build anything on a faulty
foundation where there's where it's
being and what I mean by that is that
the higher levels
are being filled by deficiencies that
haven't been taken care of maybe it's a
incessant quest for a glory or an
assistant quest for to be liked or for
connection or or safety when
transcendence is being fueled by those
deficiencies it's not a well integrated
unit you know I'm saying really the most
effective forms of of growth and
transcendence we call real growth is one
that is not motivated anymore by the
deficiencies of our basic needs but is
motivated by exploration and love for
for the love in the sense of a
humanitarian love for all humankind to
help uplift the species not just
yourself and and and they have very
different flavours to them these two
forms of growth so how do we get started
I think right Scott this sounds great
I'm gonna get me some of that
self-actualization I'm gonna help raise
everybody up why do I start it's it's
interesting I think that you need to do
a real honest assessment of where you're
at because you know you're asking me
where do you start but there's such
individual differences in where people
are starting at you know who are
listening to this podcast you could have
some people starting at the point where
their basic safety needs are the most
pressing at the moment and and that's
very fair considering the state of the
world right now this you know what
indeed I'm looking at my calendar of
March 18th 2020 I can't even remember
the year in this place for so long you
know with you know scared you you know
to leave that I don't even know what the
day is or a year but I'm well yeah yeah
but people start you have to really have
an honest real honest assessment of
where you are and I do my website I try
to I free personality self-actualization
personality test to help you figure of a
cess
what I have a self-actualization test of
ten different dimensions you can see
which of the dimensions are you most
efficient in at the moment and what what
you want to work on because this path of
self-actualization is so unique to each
individual
so I I stay away from from advice of
like you need to start here because I
want to know where really do you need to
start from so that would have success
which of your needs is it is it the
safety one is it your connection that's
holding you back from self actualizing
it may be you feeling lonely these days
you should listen to that you know I
think a lot of people pseudo grow or
become pseudo great pseudo great sounds
even funnier doesn't like it yes you
know everything I want some pseudo cake
and pseudo toothpaste it sounds funny
actually suited to be your always pseudo
great it's like if I can put down yeah
like a bottle put down it's like a wrap
exactly the first time I ever used that
phrase but but I'm saying like you may
think you've achieved greatness and
people might tell you you you're great
but maybe you're suffering with with
profound loneliness and and that's
important that's an important signal I
would say you need to start there
don't start with how great you you think
you are start with start with the
loneliness part or maybe maybe you
actually struggle with the with esteem
issues self-esteem issues and maybe
that's that's where you need to start
maybe you're you getting your validation
from others too much and you're not feel
you feel like who am i anymore i'll
apart from my likes on twitter you know
maybe maybe that's confusing you and so
you should start there so i think that
there are lots of places a lot of entry
ways that's what I'm saying mmm-hmm
depending depending on where you're at
right now I wonder how many people that
are listening feeling a little bit of a
pang there as we go through some of the
common the common issues that you've got
the safety perhaps talking about
financial worries you know money worries
future worries basic stuff or connection
did an episode with Lydia Dan Worth
who's just written a book
friendship talking about this loneliness
epidemic which is apparently sweeping
America you know this lack of connection
that we've got and how online
friendships don't supplement for
real-world ones or then on top of that
layer on on again about this potential
lack of self esteem we're using likes
and likability online as a proxy for the
way that we feel you know for our actual
self esteem so yeah I think there's
probably a few people now that are
feeling that pang inside that I want to
UM yeah a lot of people more than a few
yeah for sure um I want to talk about
peak experiences let me tell us about
what you looked up to do with that in
the book if that's a that's a phrase
Maslow used to talk about what are the
most wondrous moments of our lives that
make life worth living
no big deal NBD some sounds like I want
more of them yeah yeah and and and he
really said ah I set out to discover
what are all the different ways people
can satisfy that can have peak
experiences and they could take a lot of
different forms and interestingly enough
he found a lot of women reported
childbirth as being their greatest peak
experience and how do you have one
eyebrow go up and the other one stay put
that was from when I was in school and I
really really wanted to be Dwayne the
rock Johnson and I practiced and
practiced and practice but I can only do
it on one side it's amazing yeah it's
just his toss her own predict whether
you can do that because I can't do that
it's got nothing to do with testosterone
I think it's got everything to do with
me being a closet WWE nerd throughout
most of my secondary school and that
being like the one didn't learn to do
the DDT or the German suplex but I could
raise I could do the people's eyebrow
and now it just comes out when I'm
slightly intrigued Oh interesting so I'm
intrigued so go on that's impressive
well do you remember what I actually
said that it caused that that eyebrow to
go up no
in my defense I'm dealing with
coronavirus yeah I know I know
um so we were talking about like I'm
gonna knock on wood because that might
not be true right yeah some virus at the
moment yeah I mean if I've got a virus
and I'm self isolating and it's not
covered 19 I'm gonna be so pissed off
because I'm just at home what a waste
I know during this time and also it's
the trendy virus that everyone wants at
the moment right you know I don't want I
don't want last year's virus I want this
year as well you watch do you watch Curb
Your Enthusiasm yes bits and bytes I'm
not saying all of it yeah this is
something where David would do is to
just use an excuse whenever people like
hey where are you why are you being such
a got I got the corona but you know
being awkward on a first date you know
and like and they're like in the lady
girls like why the wait he's like why
you speak so awkward like I got Corona
thank you yeah it's a guy of jail free
card peak experiences childbirth that
was and the guy the guy with corona
virus brings it home let's get it was
well I've been known this is what I've
known for as my legacy is tangents yeah
so there are lots of different things
from from childbirth to to watching a
sunset to overcoming a great challenge
to coming up with a having an insight an
idea you know I'm sure Albert Einstein
had moments of peak experiences on his
desk you know it not on as at his desk
you know so you know these sorts of very
varied things can be triggers of peak
experiences and and and yet
Mazal realized the last year last year
and a half of his life that maybe peak
experiences weren't the most profound
moments of transcendence we could have
as a species he started to discover what
he called plateau experiences which a
lot of people don't know about in his
writing and Hutto experiences he
described it as
like lounging in heaven not getting so
excited about it it's basically being
able to cultivate a mild form of peak
experiences throughout your whole day
where you have you cultivate more
sustainably a sense of wonder and a
sense of gratitude and and and all four
four things in your in your in your
moment to moment experience not these
one-off profound peak experiences and he
only discovered that when he confronted
his mortality when he confronted his
potential for a heart attack that he
could have any time because he had won
and survived it and he said that living
this post-mortem life was what he called
it turned out to be the biggest trigger
of of transcendence than I ever realized
in all my theories so I think that peak
experiences are very important and and
can really help open us up to greater
possibilities for herself and others but
I think ultimately the wisdom there that
Mads was talking about it and which a
lot of Buddhist practitioners talk about
he drew a lot on the Buddhist and Indian
traditions as well his colleague ua
ansari actually is the one who really
brought to prominence the idea of the
plateau experience he just co-opted the
term from his East Indian colleague but
these are things that we can cultivate
in our moment-to-moment experience
because this is this is all we got is
the moment sit shy of childbirth shy of
me having to get myself pregnant which
there's a number of hurdles for me to
overcome there how your voice is way too
deep well that's another one I hadn't
even thought of that
um how can I have new to use I'm saying
to be okay how can I have more
transcendent experiences in my
day-to-day life I don't want to have to
jump off a skyscraper I don't want to
have to give birth every day well some
of the most what are worse your what let
me ask you what are some of the
triggers that you can think of that
you've noticed in your past have have
been a trigger for a peak experience
what are some of the themes so visual
beauty certainly I like to travel I like
to yell I like to go places recently
went to Bali and Indonesia and there's a
tiny little island called gili t which
has just the most phenomenal sunsets
you've ever seen now in the middle of
the ocean that was that was just
outrageous
certainly some of the conversations that
I have you know when I get to podcast
when I'm in full flow when I don't look
at the clock and I don't think about
anything else you know I'm just I'm
fully engrossed in why I'm talking about
this flow between me and the guest
during a big hug for me yeah yeah I
really do
I pity people who don't have that outlet
in their life you know that don't have
the outlet for genuine deep rigorous
conversation because there's so it's the
freest thing you're ever gonna get you
just need you in a and a buddy and
really badly unbelievably unbelievably
favorite workouts a hard workout in a
class with my with my friends again as
well maybe your you know doing a WOD
somewhere reading sometimes as well like
reading a book at the moment the moral
animal by Robert Wright I just can't put
the Sun down I talked to him yesterday
no way yeah he's Angie I've got told to
read it for ages reading reading a book
oh my god that's so cool oh my god
that's so and you just keep on going
keep on going to knit up chewing it up
seven Eve's by Neal Stephenson as well
that was a sci-fi book that I read and
that just I was staying up until 2:00 in
the morning to read a book I haven't
done that since I was what I don't know
if I've ever done that before you know
that stuff like that so there's there's
some of mine beautiful so trying to I'm
try to think of the common theme among
all those all those things that you just
mentioned so there's one that comes to
mind for me is presence fall for sure
for sure yeah yeah that's
undeniable aspect and that's a common
characteristic of anyone in the in the
throes of the peak experience so to
speak I mean the modern there's a
modern-day term that is used a lot which
is flow that Mihai csikszentmihalyi has
talked about but the flow concept has
been tied so much to performance and
that wasn't really the spirit of
Maslow's notion of peak experiences if
anything the peak experience is when
you're not trying to perform at all
right you're really being he called it
he called it moments of pure being his
what he referred to that sounds a little
woowoo but what does that mean that can
be unpack the the notion of pure being
you know and and you're kind of bringing
your whole self to the table and all of
your powers to the table and you're not
being self-critical of it you're you're
you have a lot you have as many degrees
of freedom as possible in the moment
because you're not being inhibited by
your fears and by your anxieties and my
grandma would say oh you're Michigan
totally unencumbered right and I get it
as well the the flow dynamic that always
did sit a slightly askew for me I'm not
trying to do something which is both
challenging and worthwhile at the limits
of my performance when I watch a sunset
I'm not trying to watch the sunset with
Scott we are we are brothers in mind my
friend yeah I'm not I'm not trying to
watch the sunset better than last time
watch the sunset better than the person
next to me you could definitely use it
as a meditative experience in me that
right okay well I want to be as present
as I can be I don't think that that's
that's trying to push it too far but
yeah there's there's no there's no top
leaderboard of who watched the sunset
the best exactly right and it also
doesn't explain why people report their
greatest
peak experiences when they're in tune
with another human being and you
mentioned that as one of your triggers
it's a it's a great trigger for me to
when there's a great synchronicity
between
you and another person and it usually
happens when you're not trying to change
the the person all I mean Carl Rogers
does have a beautiful quote about that
Carl Rogers is a humanistic
psychotherapist and he he's like when
you're looking at sunset you're not like
oh I wish I could just change that
corner a little bit move it up a little
you just admire it for what it is and
treating humans like that as well
is is gonna make it increase the
likelihood that you'll have a peak
experience with that person you're
there's no challenge that like the
concept of flow doesn't seem to apply in
so many experiences that we could call
peak experiences I think you're right so
how do we move from the peak experiences
to the peak Plateau
how do I make the sunset last all day
well I don't know if we if the goal is
to make the sunset lasts all day but I
think the goal is more how can we make
the moment last while the sunset is
still there that might be subtle subtle
difference because part of this highest
state of consciousness that Maslow was
talking about in in the potato
experience is your ability to
simultaneously be present in the moment
but also be aware of the impermanence of
the moment is actually this
juxtaposition that allows us to have
that sense of transcendence he would
have exercises where he would say you
know talk to someone and imagine why
you're talking to them that this is the
last time that he'll ever talk to that
person forevermore
how does that change your your presence
with this person you know and I think
that
came with a whole list of these
activities of pure being which I have in
the book hit us hit us with some I want
to know some of them Scott yeah this is
how living in the realm of pure being
perceive the eternal intrinsic laws of
the cosmos no big deal easy one easy
what I do sometimes I do that before
breakfast
yeah me too to accept or even love these
laws as taua stick in the essence of a
good citizen of the universe embrace
your past and embrace your guilt rather
than running from it be compassionate
with yourself be understanding accepting
forgiving and perhaps even evolving
about your your I don't even have
pronounce the word full laws for laws
foi BL es as expression for human each
foibles foibles their makeup foibles as
expressions of human nature enjoy and
smile at yourself ask yourself how would
the situation look to a child to the
innocent to a very old person who is
beyond personal ambition and competition
try to recover the sense of the
miraculous about life for example a baby
is a miracle think for that baby now
anything could happen and the sky is the
limit
cultivate the sense of infinite
possibility the sense of admiration all
respect and wonder may I'll just give
you one more one of them are my
favorites today I really like this one
if you find yourself
and I actually practice this one I try
if you find yourself becoming realistic
arrogant conceited or puffed up think of
mortality or think of other arrogant and
conceited people and see how they look
do you want to look like that do you
want to take yourself that seriously to
be that on humerus I really like that
that third party perspective is it's so
powerful the end I'm sorry : just the
ability to look at to look at yourself
as if you were a friend you know as if
you're a friend looking at you watching
your actions because you just strip away
all the biases all of the attachments
and you go yeah that if I saw my friend
do that that would be it'll be kinda
that'd be kind of weird absolutely and I
think that
I often know who I want to be by seeing
great examples of people I don't want to
be do you know do you ever you know do
you ever just like see someone and
you're like that's not that's not my
that wouldn't be my best self come on I
learn from other people's failures more
than other people's successes
I think boom well drop the mic on that
one I love it I love a mic drop man
that's why I'm here for ya honestly I do
I'm what's that quote I can't remember
the guy might be Peter Thiel he say any
idiot can learn from their own
experience I prefer to learn from the
experiences of others yeah yeah I mean
and there's so much that's why grey
literature stands the test of time some
of the greatest literature are great
stories that transcend the ages of
people failing in all sorts of ways and
yeah there's not there's not not a lot
of examples of great literature there
about do to do a story of a person who
had it all great live their life great
then it was fine yeah it was all good
you know we were you know we passed down
from generations to generations
archetypes of failures that we can all
resonate with and learn from I want to
talk about familiarization and and fresh
experiences and how this relates to
transcendence can you focus can you talk
to us about that yes so psychotic and I
can talk about different levels of
nerdiness
pick a level from 1 to 5 I won 5 big
super nerdy I want 5 please thank you
okay
all right well you chose a deep end come
on Scott psychologists have studied a
concept called latent inhibition which
is a biological gating mechanism that we
share with other animals that
automatically tags our experience as
relevant or irrelevant to a goal that we
have in our mind our brain does it at a
very subconscious an automatic level it
turns out that people who are very
creative tend to have a very low latent
inhibition they're very unlikely to tag
any
perience automatically is as irrelevant
and and and inhibit the experience or
idea or or things coming into their
visual field as as irrelevant and and
and and mark it away and and and take it
away from the experience so people who
are creative and another way of saying
that is that they treat experiences that
they may have experienced before is
irrelevant they experience it as fresh
every time that they see it you know
this lead this lead inhibition mechanism
that we evolved from other and which
which we share with other animals is
important so that we don't as the
existential philosopher søren
Kierkegaard said we don't drown in
possibility you know it's important to
have some sort of gating mechanism but
it's also important not to have too much
you know it's important yes it's true to
learn from the past what is relevant
what's irrelevant and and to tag things
as irrelevant if we experience them
again in a particular context but for
creative people often what seemed
irrelevant becomes a great insight
eventually becomes becomes relevant
someday you have to be open to the fact
that what was once irrelevant may become
relevant I had an example that on
Twitter just yesterday where an idea I
was obsessed about during my
dissertation for five years I wrote I
wrote the published paper no one no one
cared about the paper a whole decade
later you know feel like you know a
failure for my dissertation is all its
relevance of the study to the world we
live in today and I tweeted out viral it
went viral
amongst nerdy scientists but that's
still that's something that's still
something and and I is suddenly relevant
so you have to constantly have the faith
as a creative human being that things
that you
or things they're meaningful to you that
they'll matter and but also it's
important to have a newness of
appreciation of things constantly you
know it's great to have gratitude for
new things in your life that are good
but it's even better to have gratitude
for the things that that have become
stale to others that makes sense
absolutely yeah there's a million a
million dollars I have to open at the
moment so I'm gonna guess this relates
to the learners brain or the learners
mind in a way well yeah the beginner's
mind
yeah the beginners beginners mindset
where the first time you see something
you kind of take more of it in
I had Laura Van de Kamp who wrote off
the clock on last year and she was
talking about how one of the best
examples of a beginner's learners
mindset is when you go on holiday and
it's for instance I can't tell you
anything about my drive to work from the
last six months but I can tell you the
type of shoes and the book that the guy
that walked us to our boat in Africa two
years ago was wearing you know the exact
color of the book I know how it looked
in his hand I know the way that he
walked I know the color of his jacket
why and her argument you may be able to
tell us her argument was that when your
brain gets exposed to new novel
experiences it doesn't know what it'll
need to remember therefore it kind of
opens up intends to sponge in more I
also guess that just generally when
you're somewhere new your desire to be
present you're not distracted you're not
looking at your phone you're not
thinking about something else your holy
[ __ ] I mean Africa look at this look at
this guy look at his book look issues
that's that's true for sure also the
emotional experience the the valence of
the emotional experience matters I wrote
an article for Scientific American which
your your audience might be interested
in let's see thank you know an odor
below link will be in show notes below
let me see if I can find the actual
title of it so I don't make up the title
on here in this spot I love your own of
your own article lipstick oh that would
be about looking good
exact look let's see I try to avoid bad
looks okay
emotionally extreme experiences not just
positive or negative experiences are
more
full in life so what this really it's
actually the Pope the peak experiences
thing peak experiences are tend to be
the most memorable moments in our lives
and it's not just you know so it's not
just the positive or negative aspect of
it so that also applies to two negative
aspects of our lives
they still become the most meaningful
moments in our lives not saying we don't
we wouldn't rather not have some of
those negative moments but it's really
the the emotional valence of it just how
much it impacts us at that it touches us
at an emotional level that that is the
source of meaning for us not just
whether it was positive or negative I've
been thinking about this a little bit
recently actually as I was talking about
living on the edge and everybody that's
listening plus yourself will have some
friends who tend to shy away from the
bottom 25 in the top 25 percent of
extremeness with an experience both good
and bad right they like to live in that
inter quartile range they like to live
in that middle 50% and it does feel
quite comfortable but there's a reason
that edges are there right Edu's
wouldn't be there if they weren't there
for you to stand on them and there's
nothing more exciting than staring over
the edge of a building and I really I
really do think that as we start to push
ourselves out towards obviously you need
to do it safely like I am NOT your
doctor every disclaimer under the Sun
but you need to allow yourself to go out
and experience and I wonder as well
whether in a world where were we have
more so much more convenience I can get
my uber to the store to deliver room a
gourmet burger back to the house where I
watched my Netflix and I don't get you
know Amazon Prime next outfit through
the door I wonder whether we are nerfing
the edges of the extremeness and the
intensity of experience in the modern
world
yeah we are what were we like like
people like to fear monger because fear
mongering sells when I say people I mean
marketers by people I mean douchebags
now okay do you know what I mean like
that that's what's they do whatever
sells they'll do it so you know right
now you know the coronavirus scare you
see on Facebook everyone is selling like
oh I have the best p95 face mask
everyone else fear-mongering well what
actually is better for growth is to be
excited by by the challenge you know as
opposed to fear it and avoid it there's
a form of psychotherapy called act
acceptance commitment therapy know if
you've heard of it where it shows that
experiential avoidance
is one of the greatest sources of mental
illness and that the reverse of that
which which which psychologists call
psychological flexibility or Maslow
would actually refer to refer to that as
well I would I would Scott Barry Kaufman
would refer to that as exploration yeah
you know like the spirit of exploration
allows us to even to be actually excited
by things that most people would fear as
a challenge to overcome life is not
lived from the comfort of your couch man
like it really isn't and the more that I
spend time being able to do what I want
I remember this I have a wonderful
amount of freedom and liberty in my
day-to-day life and I have to check
myself to make sure that I'm not taking
the path of least resistance because it
can become painfully convenient is that
does that make sense
Iqbal gas becomes destructively
convenient so I need to consistently try
and find
novelty intensity new people new things
to do but I also think it can also it
totally identifies why we might have a
crisis of meaninglessness and
existential dread and all this sort of
stuff because when you're not fighting
the lion at the door who's trying to eat
half your family or worrying about where
your next meal comes from well why
should you really bother about anything
I can just get Amazon delivered through
the door I'd you know everything's chill
it's fine but that does lead to the
crisis because you're so the bottom of
Maslow's hierarchy of needs is so well
serviced that we now have to actually
make a decision about what to do to get
to the top and in a meritocracy if the
people who fail if the people who
succeed are worthy of their own success
and the people who fail are worthy of
their own failures and I think that
that's right that means that people can
get real real scared that's not my idea
that is the idea of Alain de Botton but
thank you Elan for that one it's quite
right
and I I know that Owen has written about
Maslow's hierarchy of needs as well no
no that was that was well said can we do
I contemplate your life from a
historians point of view that sounds
really cool well that that's one of the
exercises the the the the exercises of
pure being I was I was running down the
list of the things yeah if you view
yourself from a historians perspective
you know what what is this time period
and putting it in context of prior
context you know in a lot of ways the
world is the best it's ever been in in
terms of poverty in terms of almost any
metric you look at Steven Pinker it has
written about that you know and I know
that our day to day that's cold comfort
for our day-to-day living and what may
seem like a catastrophe but it's
certainly better you know from
historians perspective certainly better
to live in 2020 with a virus than 1918
you know with influenza pandemic or I
think was called Spanish flu or
something like that you know the kind of
technologies we have
and in progress we've made this is
probably the best time in human history
to have such a pandemic right so I think
the historians perspective one is
putting things in a certain perspective
of the rest of humanity and the rest of
human history and also thinking about
100 200 years from now how will people
view the actions we made as well as is
important to think about when we take
certain actions should we be scared
Oh frightful or worried about the fact
that realistically in 75 years time no
one will remember our name or what we
did the only the only part of you that
scared of that is your ego and if you
can transcend the ego then that just
won't be a concern for you anymore that
that question
won't matter and it's not easy
transcending the ego because it's so
powerful it seems like such a driving
force for so many of us but you look at
those who've managed to transcend their
fear of death as well and and some some
of some of that comes from just taking
one good LSD trip quite frankly and and
and and seeing what it what it means to
be egoless and you can enjoy then if you
could find it sort of like a relief for
these people who can reach those moments
and said and and people reach it not
just through a host a route I should say
you know mindfulness meditation through
a lot of inner inner work on integration
and and and getting outside yourself and
helping others and you realize that it
doesn't really matter what really you
know it it matters what you what you do
in your day to day life to help other
human existence but it doesn't always
have to be this grandiose you know you
started a non-profit and a humanitarian
non
you know the stereotypical I have a
humanitarian nonprofit person you know
and they're always talking about how but
there I say this is a cheeky way because
I don't think we appreciate the person
who just by their being in the world
every day there are bling others they're
not going on Twitter immediately and
announcing it but they're giving a smile
to a stranger on the street well that
counts I mean they're you know they
there are so many things throughout the
course today that count in terms of your
existence you just maximize your
existence on a day to day basis I think
that's good enough it's like the
stereotypical great mum isn't it shout
out shout at my mum Kathy who'd be
listening thank you for for smiling at
strangers in the street and doing stuff
like that ya know exactly in fact
Abraham Maslow thought that his wife's
his wife Bertha's mom was more self
actualized than he was some woman who
probably can't even didn't even know it
wasn't really that bothered Abraham stop
talking about work at the dinner table
that all that stuff and then she's
somehow managed to achieve what he liked
more than he did yeah I mean Abraham as
well he did his mom but he really was
quite fond of his wife's mom was
interesting and he really did resent his
own mom that was and that's a whole
other story heavy because she was
superstitious and stuff but yeah but he
really thought that his wife Bertha's
mom was was really self actualized and
and she was not high achieving so it's
very clear he didn't equate
self-actualization with achievement
he really equated with with this what he
called being loved literally being loved
you know and that's not doing well
there's so many a lot of people that
that do love in in this kind of
grandiose virtue signaling sort of way
you know but are just [ __ ] to
everyone in their daily life and that's
not being love you know it's the same it
goes back to what we were talking about
before to do with the the ascetic who's
recounted all worldly
sessions but it's just a signal and I
had Robin Hanson on a year and a bit ago
and you know he's the man for signals
the elephant the elephant in the brain
right and Paul bloom had this great
quote as well when I spoke to him where
he said there is no such thing as not
giving a [ __ ]
there is only seeming like you're not
giving a [ __ ] it's like everybody's
signaling all the time it's the people
for whom I don't think that my mum is I
don't think that my mum will go and do
something nice first one of the ladies
at work like take some flowers in for a
birthday I'll do whatever I don't think
she's doing it so other people see her
taking those in you know that's right
that's exactly right yeah at the end of
the day what Maslow's whole project of
self-actualization maybe people don't
realize this
he started off just take he started what
he called the good human being no book I
mean he just took examples of people he
saw that he thought were good human
beings he didn't start off like with
even the concept self-actualization and
start off with just I want to study the
greatest specimens of good human beings
and he really believed that by studying
them he could he could like understand
human potential you know he probably but
we really should study the growing tip
of humanity which is what he called it
you know all trees have a point of their
growth where they grow the most at the
top they caused the growing tip there's
a lot there are a lot of parts of the
trees that do not grow anymore you know
so he wanted to study the growing tip of
humanity to see what we were all capable
of and and that was really about about
the good human being it wasn't about the
the one who dominated all the
competition you know or who had their
face on the cover of time the most
amount of times you know how do we we've
touched on Robert Wright earlier on and
because I've got Eve psyche in the back
of my mind all the time at the moment I
want to I want to kind of touch on that
we spoke about this transcending of the
ego bypassing some of the mechanisms
which exist or they were created because
we needed them we needed to do play the
game of hierarchy domina
scam I am look at me I am Here I am
better than this person because it was
all relative and we lived in a band of
50 people we needed to have a fear of
death because it was fitness enhancing
we needed to the X Y Z all the way along
just what does this mean for the future
what does this mean for us as we move
forward now as a race as a species what
are the humans of the future going to be
like is the hope that we're all just
going to become these kind of bonobo
super-chill free love man kind of
animals do you think that that's ever
achieve aboul Aish asking a really quite
profound question could you could you
maybe ask it again I'm essentially my
question is can we transcend our nature
that's that's the question yeah yeah I
mean it's it's a question I I wrestle
with and and not only do I think we can
say yes the answer is I do you think we
can I this is the the spirit of the book
this is the spirit of the book transcend
is that I think that in order to
transcend ourselves we have to become
greater than the sum of our parts we
have to ultimately realize that human
beings are not just a combination of all
of our evolutionary modules that we can
actually become integrated and a whole
unit that works towards a conscious
purpose of some sort and that really
makes us different than other animals a
lot of evolutionary psychologists get a
great glee from pointing out how similar
or similar we are to other animals like
look we have the same eating patterns as
the gorillas but whilst and I say whilst
because you're in England that may be
true they're not wrong I think there's
so many aspects of humans that that make
us is that make us human and that was
the spirit of Maslow in the humanistic
psychologists and I'm trying to bring
that spirit back men love it there's a
to my final quote that I've got is from
a guy called Daniels macton Berger do
you know him from civilization emerging
he's a good friend of mine no way so I
was supposed to think to him I'm
supposed to speak to him on Sunday but
we we got the time we got the times
wrong and he's got from that talk on
emergence that he gave on YouTube and in
that he has this brilliant quote which
is that as human beings because of our
level of consciousness and the fact that
we can interject into the way that we're
programmed from nature were not just
passengers were the captains of the ship
and that distinction between the two
between being a passenger and being the
captain that's it would appear that
that's kind of what we're talking about
here for sure Dana Dana and I had some
good conversations about just that topic
strolling along San Diego's streets and
I remember that I tell you what if you'd
recorded that I would have listened well
well actually you can listen to me and
him talking on his podcast a couple
years ago he had me on his podcast and
we had a great chat about
self-actualization that's awesome look
I'm conscious that I've taken up a bunch
of your time and thank you I need to I
need to let you get back because you got
with Veda coronavirus out there so
transcend is out 7th of April so link
will be in the show notes below to
pre-order and if people want to house on
you online why should they go oh really
like it if people could check out the
psychology podcast which is my own
podcast Scott Barry Kaufman calm has all
the episodes as well as a lot a free
self actualization personality tests
they can take so Scott Barry Kaufman
calm and then also on Twitter I'm very
active on Twitter if you want to see my
hey my half-baked ramblings on Twitter I
go viral with a bunch of a bunch of
psychology nerds that's what I want to
see oh yes my most recent tweet did
pretty well showing that IQ is different
arguing and study I did my dissertation
my doctoral dissertation that IQ is not
the same thing as the motivation for
truth seeking there are different things
now that if ever I've heard a title that
is Daniel SH Martin burger it is that
one
wonderful yeah you know I mean yeah yeah
yeah for sure
Scot man thank you so much for your time
links to everything that we've spoken
about will be in the show notes below of
course transcend new science of self
actualization will be in their
psychology podcast Scott very calm calm
all that good stuff you know what to do
like share and subscribe if you got any
questions feel free to get in touch with
me
but for now Scott thanks man thank you
Chris was a great chat
[Music]